my lady I can't read the word you can't
I'll teach you I'll come when Bert's on
duty intention its easing
it'll be fun rule we can't why not what
would they do look as himself you see a
E and G together like that it sounds
like egg when last one was five he said
of e I don't ever want to die I wanted
to say to him you won't child you won't
ever I hated the idea of him lying awake
in the dark afraid
I think mothers and fathers made up the
gods because they wanted their children
to sleep through the night on the first
nigut night why is the Regine night I
don't know that just this my books the
better than these boring Scrolls you
could read about balerion the dread they
say you can still see his skull in the
dungeons beneath the red keep I have a
trying to stay out of those dungeons my
whole life don't stop there's bread and
water go slow with it how thirsty you
get don't drink seawater
not to drink seawater you ever been in a
boat before huh you know how to swim no
don't fall out the hand of the king
doesn't have much later time you won't
be a very good hand if you see the word
and I to say curtain once weeks ago that
you're your father's daughter enormous
dick bloody relentless and forth are
here you'll never read well if you move
your lips
that's not children do it
you were pirate once no I was never a
pirate half as a smuggler what's the
difference well if you're a famous
smuggler you're not doing it right I
need you to write a message you should
write it yourself it's good practice
just reporting for me I need a smart
person to do it I'm not scared
well I am the battle comes promise
you'll protect me I made you something
princess do you like it
he's beautiful thank you you're very
welcome
will you meet me at don't you so fifty
can have company console with this is my
own cool way of saying thank you for
cheating me to be a prawn I'll be gone
for a few days princess I want to hear
all about the dance of dragons when I'm
bike you will read it yourself it was
the only way you burnt a little girl
alive I only do what my Lord commands
you to burn children your Lord is evil I
loved that girl like she was my own she
was good she was kind and your Gilda you
fight her for as long as you can you'll
clean up as much of this [ __ ] as you can
a fail goda
now go fail again
we are not a large house and every month
of their island fights for the strength
of ten mainlanders if they're half as
ferocious as their lady
the Bolton's are doomed she has a good
heart a good heart I've notice just
staring at a good heart there's no time
for that you came to get me you want me
to come with you I think you need to
understand I'm ready
yeah let's go this this I know I want to
fight too
I'm going to be encrypt with my son now
to feel a lot better with you down there
to protect us sure a lot of people would
all right I'll defend Krypton